We were talking last time about the
establishment of the monarchy or kingship,
um,
in Israel.
And I want to say a little bit about some
of the features of Israelite kingship.
And today I'll be coming back frequently
to the Israelite notions of kingship
and, and royal ideology.
But to start off, uh,
one of the most important things to
realize is that the king in Israel was not
divine, uh, as he was in
Egypt or even semi divine.
Occasionally he offered sacrifice, but he
didn't play a regular role in the cult.
Israelite Royal Ideology was heavily
indebted to Canaanite Royal Ideology.
You have similar language that's
applied to the kings of Israel.
The king is said to be appointed by the,
by the deity or deities to end
wickedness to enlighten the land.
He's the channel of press, prosperity
and divine blessing for the nation.
All of this is true of Canaanite
kings as well. And the king,
as we've seen is spoken of as God's son.
That doesn't imply divinity.
It's a metaphor.
The metaphor of son ship.
It was used for the
Canaanite gods as well.
And it expressed the special relationship
between the king and the deity.
It was the same relationship as was found
between that of as Susan and a vassal
Lennar suzerainty treaties. Also the
vessel is the son of, of the Susan.
It's a kind of adoption and
what it means is that the,
the one who is metaphorically
the sun is to serve, uh,
the father loyally faithfully,
but is also susceptible
to chastisement from him.
And that's what we saw in Nathan's
statement or pronouncement of prophecy to
David last time.
Michael Coogan points out that the
notion of the sun ship of the king was
revolutionary.
It was a deliberate effort to replace
an earlier understanding according to
which the entire nation
of Israel was God's son.
You'll be remembered during the plagues
in Egypt and God refers to Pharaoh as
having a pressed his son
Israel, his first born as, yeah,
for his son.
The king now is standing between
God and the people as a whole.
And we're going to be turned to a moment
in a moment to this new royal ideology
and, and what's really going to be a very
tense juxtaposition with the Covenant
Theology.
But first I want to say a little bit
more about the characters of David and
Solomon before going into
the way royal ideology was,
was later developed in the Bible.
David is second only in importance
and in textual space to Moses write,
the amount of space is devoted to
him. Um, it's second only to Moses.
There are three characteristics of David,
which stand out.
And the first is that he's described
as being quite proficient in music and
poetry. And so we'll see that later.
Tradition is going to attribute to him,
uh, not only the invention
of various instruments,
but also the composition
of the book of Psalms.
It seems to make sense that he would be
the composer of the Book of Psalms if he
has a reputation for,
for poetry and music.
He's also credited with great military
and tactical skill and confidence.
He deploys his army on behalf of Israel,
but he also once he is king,
deploys a his army within
Israel against his rivals.
Third,
he's depicted as a very shrewd politician
and it was David who created permanent
symbols of God's election of Israel.
God's election of David himself,
God's election of David's house or
line or dynasty to rule over Israel in
perpetuity. It has said that he
conceived the idea of a royal capital.
He captured the city of Jay Boosie
gay boosts. It was a border town,
so it's free of any tribal association,
right? It's sort of like a Washington DC.
It's not located really within any one
tribe and he captured this and built it
up as the city of David.
The city was going to be renamed Jerusalem
and it would become understood as the
chosen city, the place where God caused
his name to dwell. As Deuteronomy said,
there would be a place where God would
choose to cause his name to dwell,
and so Jerusalem becomes a
symbol of God's presence.
It becomes a symbol of Israel's kingdom,
a monarchy.
It becomes a symbol of
the dynasty of David.
It is referred to as the city of David.
David transfers the arc to this city.
And so he makes it the home to the
ancient witness of the Covenant,
the Sinai Covenant.
The added implication is that the Davidic
dynasty has inherited the blessings of
the covenant is Somehow Fulfilling
The promise to the Patriarchs, which,
which is also associated with
the nation of Israel. At Sinai,
he planned a temple that would become
the permanent resting place for the arc
and a cultic center for all Israel.
But the building of this
temple was left to Solomon.
So we'll discuss it and it's
symbolism when we get to Solomon.
But according to the biblical record,
it was still David who made the
Choson Dynasty, the chosen city,
what would eventually be the temple
into permanent and deeply interconnected
symbols of the religion of Israel.
And it's really with David that the
history of Jerusalem as the holy city, uh,
begins.
Now.
The Biblical assessment of David is
initially a relatively positive and this
changes, uh, shortly after
his ascension to the throne,
beginning in Second Samuel from
about chapter nine through 20.
And then on into the first
couple of chapters of kings,
you have a stretch of texts,
which is often referred to as the court
history or the succession narrative of
David.
The critical question that drives this
particular historical fiction is the
question of fixed session. Who will
succeed? David, he has many children,
but one by one his sons are um,
killed or this they're displaced or
disqualified in one way or another.
Until finally there is Solomon.
There are lots of wonderful,
major and minor characters in this drama.
It's a very complex drama,
lots of intrigue and passion.
But the passages of the material in this
section also presents a rather unusual
portrait of David. He's
weak, he's indecisive,
he's something of an Antihero.
He stays home and the palace,
while other people are off leading
battles and, and then fighting the wars.
He enters into a knee,
illicit relationship with a married woman,
but Shev or Bathsheba,
uh,
he sees to it that her husband is
killed in battle to cover up his affair.
Um,
it's this combined act of adultery
and murder that earns him,
um, of sounds scolding from
Nathan the Prophet Nathan. We'll,
we'll come to that when we
talk about profits next week.
But God punishes him, uh,
with the death of his son.
And it's really from this point
on in the story that we see David,
I'm losing control over events around him.
His control declines. Um, he is,
he's indecisive on the whole question of
succession and that leads to all kinds
of resentment and conflict
as well as result revolts.
There's one revolt which is a revolt
in support of his son Absalom.
That's a revolt that the Deuteronomistic
historian also indicates was a
punishment for his affair with date
for David's affair with Bathsheba.
But during this revolt, uh,
David flees from his enemies.
He stripped of his
crown, he's degraded, um,
when Absalom is killed,
David weeps for his son uncontrollably.
And this only angers
his own supporters who,
who fought so earnestly against
Absalom and his defense.
It's very pointed moment, but by
the end of the story, David is, um,
almost completely impotent and,
and senile even the Prophet Nathan.
And Best Sheba plot to have,
um,
Bashiva's son Solomon a
named the successor of David.
And there really is no point at which
there's any divine indication that Solomon
has has one divine approval,
no divine indication that he is the
one it happens through palace intrigue,
particularly with Bathsheba and
Nathan, but the northern tribes. Um,
there are signs throughout the story of
the hostility of the northern tribes.
And that's a warning sign.
That's a warning sign of future disunity.
This whole court history is just a
wonderful, masterful work of prose.
You're going to be reading, um, uh,
something from a book by a
Fella named Mayor Sternberg,
which is I think just a wonderful
study of the bus Shiva story. Um,
some speak about all of this unit
as being authored by the net, by,
by the j source.
Um,
you need to know that source theory
has undergone so many permutations.
There really isn't any standard view,
but I think the idea that the sources
jep and d extend beyond the pentitude
cause now generally
not no longer accepted.
So you will sometimes see people talking
about the j source is going all the way
through the end of second kings and being,
in fact the J is the author of the,
of the court history.
But for the most part I think most people
think of the source theory is applying
to the Pentateuch.
And beyond that we talk about the
Deuteronomistic historian redacting older
earlier sources.
We'll talk a little bit more about some
of those sources as we move through the
later books. The books of the
form of profits, the whore,
the court history has an array of
very richly drawn characters. Um,
they act out all sorts of scenes
of, of um, power and lust and,
and courage and struggle. There's,
there's crime, there's tender love.
It's a very realistic sort of,
of psychological drama. Um,
it's also striking for its
uncompromising honesty.
We don't see anything like that really in
the work of any contemporary historian.
David is depicted in very,
very human terms.
The flattery and the white washing that
you find in other ancient near Eastern,
um,
dynastic histories is lacking here.
The flattery and white washing that
we get. For example, in in chronicles,
I write the books of chronicles are really
just a retelling of the material here
in the form of profits. And they clean
up the picture of David that you know,
there's no mention of Bathsheba in there.
So you do have that kind of whitewashing
as part of the historiography of the
book of chronicles. But it's
lacking here. All of the flaws,
all of the weaknesses of
David a national hero,
they're all laid bare implicitly.
Perhaps that is a critique of kingship.
It's perhaps a critique of the claim
of kings to rule by divine right.
The author here seems to be stressing that
David, and as we shall see, Solomon, um,
he's quite human, Solomon's quite
human. They're not at all divine.
They're subject to the errors and
flaws that characterize all humans.
As we move out of Samuel now
and into first and second kings,
we see that these books,
kings contained the history of Israel
from the death of King David until the
fall of Judah in five 80 75
86 and the exile to Babylonia.
These books also appeared to
be based on older sources.
Some of them are explicitly identify,
they will refer sometimes to these works,
which evidently were subsequently lost,
but they'll say they'll refer to the book
of the acts of Solomon or the book of
the annals of the kings of Israel or
the book of the annals of the kings of
Judah.
Animals and chronicles were regularly
maintained in royal courts throughout the
ancient Near East.
There's no reason to think that this
wasn't also done in a royal setting in
Israel.
These animals generally listed events,
important events in the
reign of a given king.
They tended not to have
much narrative to them.
And the beginning of the first 16 chapters
of first kings has that kind of feel,
not a lot of narrative and
really reportage of events.
Beginning in first king 1717 through 22,
the first nine chapters of seven kings,
there's a departure from
that analyst analytic,
not an analytic ana Anil
style animals genre, um,
the reporting of events,
uh, in the reign of a king.
And you have more developed
narratives in those sources.
And these narratives
generally feature profits.
So it's going to lead very nicely into
our study of profits beginning on Monday.
Some of the narratives evidently would
have circulated independently. Um,
particularly the stories
probably about Elijah and Elisha.
These zealous Yahweh only profits.
They were probably local heroes and
these stories circulate it independently,
but they've come to be embedded in a
framework that conforms those sources to
um, the ideology and religious perspective
of the Deuteronomistic historian.
Uh, first kings chapter two is, is
the death scene. Um, it has, um,
David's death bed instructions to his
son Solomon and he tells Solomon to kill
all of his rivals and opponents.
And in verse 12,
we read and Solomon sat upon
the throne of his father David.
And his rule was firmly established
and it seems that at this point,
the three crises that we noted in the
book of Samuel at the opening of first
Samuel, the three crises we noted are
resolved. The crisis in succession is,
is resolved.
David is succeeded by his son,
Solomon and all of the kings of Judah
for the next 400 years. In fact,
until the destruction in five 86,
um,
all of these kings will
be of the Line of David.
The military crises seem for
now to have been resolved.
We've had lots of military and diplomatic
successes and Israel seems to be
secure. And also the religious
crisis that we mentioned is resolved.
The Ark was taken from the Philistines.
It's been brought to Jerusalem,
it's been installed in Jerusalem, and
now a magnificent temple is planned, um,
that will, how's the arc and be a site
for the central worship of all Israel.
But the resolution of these crises came
at a cost and they produced fundamental
changes in Israelite Society from
a loose confederation of tribes.
However idealistic that picture was.
But from a loose confederation of
tribes are United by a covenant.
We've now got a nation with a
strong central administration.
It's headed by a king.
And that king seems to enjoy a special
covenant with God rather than charismatic
leaders who rise as the need, um,
itself arises and then fade away.
We now have permanent kings from a single
family and preserved in the biblical
sources is attention,
attention between the old ideas
of the Covenant Confederation,
What We Might Call Covenant Theology,
and the new ideology of the monarchy.
This new royal ideology combines loyalty
to God and loyalty to the throne so
that treason or rebellion against
God's anointed is also apostasy.
It's also rebellion against God himself,
the to become conflated.
A as a scholar named Jon Levenson,
I've talked about him before and
connection with the Covenant at Sinai,
but in this wonderful
book called Sinai in Zion,
he really juxtaposes these two ideologies
and he points to this deep tension
between the Covenant Theology and the
Royal Ideology in Covenant Theology.
Yahweh,
he alone is the king.
He's got a direct suzerain vassal
relationship with the people.
So Israel is the subject
of Covenant Theology. Um,
the Covenant Theology therefore implies,
implies almost automatically as
somewhat negative view of the monarchy.
And that's what we've
seen here and there in a,
in the book of judges and in
Samuel monarchy is at best,
unnecessary,
and at worst it's a rejection of God.
Nevertheless, despite that
resistance or that critique monarchy,
kingship is established in Israel,
and 11 cents sees the royal ideology that
developed to support this institution
as a major revolution in the
structure of the religion of Israel,
where the Synetic covenant was
contracted between God and the nation.
The davidic covenant is contracted between
God and a single individual. The king,
the Covenant with David. Um,
another scholar, Moshe Weinfeld,
who I've mentioned before as well.
Um,
he describes the Covenant With
David as a covenant of grant.
This is a form that we find
in the ancient near eastern,
in the ancient near east. Also, it's a,
it's a grant of a reward
for loyal service and deeds.
And so God rewards David with
the gift of an unending dynasty.
It's a covenant of grantee grants him
this unending dynasty in exchange for his
loyalty.
And the contrast with the Covenant
at Sinai is very clear where Israel's
covenant with God at Sinai
had been conditional.
It's premised on the observance of
God's Torah. If there's violation,
then God will uproot the Israelites and
throw them out of the land. All right.
The covenant with David.
By contrast with his dynastic house and
by implication with David City and and,
and the Temple of Top Mountain Zion,
that covenant will be
maintained under all conditions.
Remember the passage that we read,
if Nathan's prophecy last time?
So the royal ideology fostered
a belief in some quarters,
and we'll see this in the next few weeks,
a belief in the inviolability,
the impregnable nature
of David's house dynasty,
the city itself, the chosen city,
the sacred mountain, the temple.
We'll return to this
idea in later lectures.
So you have this deep tension lining
up Israel's covenant at Mount Sinai,
which is conditional on the one
hand with God's covenant with David,
which is centered on the temple and
Palace Complex at Mount Zion and which is
unconditional and permanent.
Scholars have tried to account for these
two strands of tradition in biblical
literature in different ways.
The Covenant Theology with its emphasis
on the conditional covenant with Moses,
I'm contracted at Sinai,
the royal ideology and its emphasis on
the unconditional covenant with David
focused on Mount Sinai on one
explanation is chronological.
That early traditions were centered
around the Sinai Event and the Covenant
Theology. They emphasize that
aspect of the relationship with God.
And later traditions under the
monarchy emphasize royal ideology.
Another explanation is geographical.
The northern kingdom,
which if you'll recall,
and we'll talk about in a moment,
the northern kingdom is going to
break away from the southern kingdom.
David [inaudible] will not
rule in the northern kingdom.
So the assumption is that
the northern kingdom,
which rejected the house of
David, they de emphasize, um,
royal ideology that end, it's focused
on Zion and the house of David.
And they emphasize cut the Old Covenant
Theology and the Sinai Theology by
contrast, the southern kingdom, uh, in
which a member of the House of David, uh,
you know, range, right?
Until the destruction.
The Southern Kingdom emphasized Zion
and its attendant royal ideology. Well,
Levenson rejects both
of these explanations.
He says the difference isn't that
one is early in, one is late.
It isn't that one is northern
and one is southern. We find, um,
the Sinai and the Xi'an Traditions
in early texts and late texts.
We find them in northern tech sentence.
Southern texts in the south.
David's house was
criticized just as roundly.
It was as it was criticized in the north
and emphasis was placed on the Sinai
Covenant over against the Royal Ideology
in the south as well as in the north.
So the two traditions he
said coexisted side by side.
They stood in a dialectic tension with
one another in Israel and eventually they
would come to be coordinated
and work together.
We'll see that more towards
the end of the lecture,
but he says the Xeon ideology will take
on some of the aspects of the legacy of
Sinai.
Mount Zion will soon be associated with
the site of God's [inaudible] or self
revelation. It will become a kind of
Sinai now permanently in Jerusalem.
It would become the site
of Covenant Renewal.
It will be seen as the place
where Torah goes forth.
And that's an idea of course,
originally associated with Sinai.
That's where it God's
instruction or Torah went first.
But all of these features will be
collapsed or telescoped are brought into a
Mount Zion and the temple complex.
But eventually he says it's not simply
that the Sinai Covenant Theology was
absorbed into Royal Ideology and Mount
Zion because the entitlement of the house
of David will eventually
be made contingent on the
observant on the observance
of God's Torah.
The king himself we will see is not
exempt from the Covenant Conditions Set at
Sinai and even though he would never
be completely deposed for violating the
Synetic covenant,
he will be punished for his violations.
The two will work in tandem.
It's an idea that will return to,
we'll see it more clearly
as we get towards the end of
this lecture, but for now,
keep in mind that the two are going to
be held intention and work together to
check one another.
Now,
David's son Solomon is given mixed
reviews by the Deuteronomistic historian.
He ascends to the throne through entry
cause I said there's really no indication
of a divine choice or approval,
but he said to reign over a golden age.
His kingdom is said to stretch
from Egypt to the Euphrates.
He made political alliances and economical
economic alliances throughout the
region. He would seal these
alliances with marriages.
He married the daughter of Pharaoh.
He married the daughter of the king
of tire and Phoenicia and so on.
The text claims that he built a
daunting military establishment.
He put a wall around Jerusalem. They
were fortified cities. Um, Hud sore,
McGee doe guesser. These were
basis for his professional army.
It's said that the army featured a
very expensive chariot force. Um,
he also had accomplishments in
the realms of industry and trade.
He exploited Israel's natural position,
straddling the north south, uh,
trade routes and, uh, was able to bring
great wealth to the state in that way.
The daily supplies that were needed to
maintain Solomon's very lavish court are
detailed in first kings.
So it seems to have been an
extraordinarily elaborate court.
He developed a merchant fleet.
He seemed to work closely
with the Phoenicians and the
Phoenician King Hiram and
developing a merchant fleet and exploited
trade routes through the Red Sea.
All sorts of exotic products are listed
as coming in to Jerusalem from Arabia
and the African coast.
We have the famous story of the
visit of the Queen of Sheba.
This could possibly be a
subbie and territory and
South Arabia and there may be
some basis,
in fact,
given these trade routes and how
well traveled they were at this time.
And of course he's known for his
magnificent building operations. Um,
many scholars assume that given
this tremendous wealth, um,
this would have been a time for the
flowering, a flowering of the arts.
And so it's often been maintained that
this would have been the time for the
early traditions,
biblical traditions,
early traditions of the
nation to be recorded.
Perhaps the J source people date it to
the 10th century, the time of Solomon.
But we should be a little skeptical of
this grand picture because archeologists
have found that Jerusalem was a
small town. It was a very small town,
really until the end
of the eighth century.
Suddenly it absorbed many refugees
from the fall of the northern kingdom.
Remember, Israel is going to
be, uh, destroyed and seven 22.
So refugees fleeing southward
will greatly expand your Islam.
We have our archeological
evidence of that,
but there are very few material remains
that a tests to a fabulous empire on the
scale that's suggested by the biblical
text had sore Mojito and guest.
They're the three places that are
mentioned as fortified military basis.
These have been excavated.
They do show some great gateways and
some large chambers, even some stables,
but archeologists differ radically
over the d the dating of um,
of these layers. Some date them to the
time of Solomon. Some see it as later. Um,
most concur that Israel was probably at
this time the most important power in
its region,
but still it would have been small and
relatively insignificant compared to the
Egypt or Mesopotamia.
Some of the great civilizations at
either end of the Fertile Crescent,
but it would have been the most important
state in that area and probably was
able to have some dominance over
some neighboring areas as well.
I just want to mention three things about
Solomon thinks that he's noted for, uh,
one is that he's praised for
his wisdom and because again,
the digital texts praises
him for his wisdom.
Later tradition will find it convenient
to attribute the book of proverbs to him
as well as the book of
Ecclesiastes. These, uh,
these are two works that belonged to
the genre of wisdom literature we'll be
talking about later in the semester.
Second,
in addition to being
praised for his wisdom,
he's praised for constructing the temple.
And in fact, the primary focus of,
of all of the biblical material with
the Biblical story of Solomon is the
building of the temple of the dedication
of this temple for the Ark of the
Covenant in Jerusalem. He continued
the close association of, of um,
of the cult and the monarchy,
the religious and political leadership
by constructing this magnificent new
Tampa within the palace,
the palace complex. Um,
and he himself appointed to high priest.
So the juxtaposition of the house of
the king and the house of the Deity on
Mount Scion was quite deliberate.
And this hill,
even though geographically
it's very small,
becomes in the mythic
imagination of Israel.
This towering and Impregnable Mountain,
uh,
11 sin again,
um,
argues that Xi'an came eventually to take
on the features of the cosmic mountain
on the cosmic mountain is a mythic symbol
that we find in the ancient near east.
Um,
the cosmic mountain has these,
these powers are potencies
that are universal and
infinite and we find it in the
religion of Israel as well. Specifically
in connection with Mount Zion.
The cosmic mountain in ancient tradition
was understood to be the meeting place
of the gods, like a Mount Olympus,
for example, as a cosmic mountain.
But it was also understood
to be the axis Mundi.
That is to say the juncture or the point
of junction between heaven and earth,
the meeting place of heaven and earth,
right.
The access around which these worlds
met or were conjoined in Canaan, um,
in Canaanite religion, the mountain of
bow, which is known as Mount soft phone,
was conceived precisely in this manner.
And Levinson points out tremendous
commonalities of language and concept,
um, in, um, in connection
with the mountain of bowel,
the mountain of El and the
mountain of yogic way. In fact,
the word soft phone mounts,
a phone is used to describe God's
mountain in the Bible in one particular,
in one particular passage.
So the temple on Mount Zion came
to be understood as sacred space,
much like the cosmic
mountains of other traditions.
It's described as a kind of paradise,
sometimes almost a garden of Eden.
It's described as the place from
which the entire world was created.
It's also viewed as a kind
of epitome of the world,
a kind of microcosm entirely an
entire microcosm of the world.
It's also seen as the earthly
manifestation of a heavenly temple.
The temple came to represent
an ideal and sacred realm,
and we also see it as the
object of intense longing.
Many of the psalms will
express intense longing.
If I could just sit in the temple, if
I could just be in that, that space,
that sacred space.
We see it in the psalms in
a passage describing the
dedication of the temples is
in first kings eight Salomon explains
that the temple is a place where people
have access to God. They can petition to
him and they can atone for their sins.
It is a house of prayer he says,
and it remained the central focal point
of Israelite worship per centuries.
So his great wisdom, his great
virtue in constructing the temple,
not withstanding Solomon,
is very sharply criticized for,
among other things, his
foreign worship. Um,
his new palace complex had a tremendous
amount of room for his Harem,
which is said to have included 700 wives.
Many of them were foreign princesses.
Many of them would have been acquired
to seel political alliances or business
alliances, noble, noble women,
700 wives and 300 concubines,
as well as various officials and servants.
Now of course these numbers
are likely exaggerated,
but Solomon's diplomatic alliances
likely necessitated unions that would of
course have been condemned by
the Deuteronomistic historian.
He is said to have loved
women from foreign women,
from the nations that God had forbid,
and he succumb to the worship
of their gods and goddesses,
which is really the key point. I mean the
whole fear of, of uh, foreign spouses,
that one will be led to or we'll
support the worship of foreign deities.
And so Solomon is said to
have built temples for Moabite
gods and ammonite gods.
Um,
this all may point to a general tolerance
for different cults in Jerusalem in
the 10th century.
And in the ninth century.
This may not have been an issue in
Jerusalem in the 10th and ninth century,
but it's an issue for the
later Deuteronomistic editor.
They have no tolerance before this.
So Solomon's primary flaw in the
Deuteronomistic historian's view is his
syncretism,
which is prompted by his marriages to
these foreign women who brought their
native cults to Jerusalem.
His religious infidelity is,
is um,
the cause is said to be the cause of
the severe problems and ultimately the
division of the kingdom that will follow
upon his death in order to support this
tremendous court. Um, and,
and Harem as well as the
army and the bureaucracy.
Solomon did introduced heavy taxation
as well as the core VA, which is, uh,
forced labor or required
labor on state projects.
So you have this developing
urban structure complex,
developing bureaucratic urban structure
that's now being super imposed,
the agricultural life.
Um,
and that leads to all sorts of class
distinctions and class divisions between
officials, bureaucrats, um, merchants,
large scale land owners
who were prospering,
perhaps smaller farmers and shepherds
who are living at more of a subsistence
level. So you have divisions between
town and country, between rich and poor.
And this is a great change from the
ideals of the tribal democracy. Uh,
some of the ideals that some of you
looked at when we were talking about legal
texts where there seem to be these
economic blueprints for bringing about
economic, um, equivalents
through sabbatical,
years and jubilee years and so on.
In short,
the list of social and economic ills
that were enumerated by Samuel in first
Samuel Chapter Eight,
when he was trying to persuade the
people from establishing a monarchy,
that list of ills, you'll have a
standing army, military, a standing army,
you'll have to support,
you'll have to do labor for this date.
You're going to have all kinds
of taxes and special levies.
You're going to be virtually and slaved.
Many of these things seem
to have been realized.
The Deuteronomistic historian would like
us to believe in the reign of Solomon.
Moreover, as we've already seen, um,
the very institution of monarchy itself
didn't sit well in some quarters because
centralized leadership under a human
king seem to go against the older
traditions of Hebrew Tribal Society,
United by Covenant with God,
guided by priests, profits, a occasional
judges inspired charismatically.
So already before Solomon's death,
the northern tribes were, uh,
feeling some alienation
from the house of David.
They're resenting what they
perceive to be Salomons tyranny.
So let me give you a brief timeline of
what happens from the death of Solomon
down to the destruction. And I'm one
of the earlier handouts I gave you.
There is a list of the
king's north and south.
This is not something you need to memorize
and I'm certainly not going to stress
it, but if you kind of
want to keep score, that's,
that's a list that you can refer to.
So when Solomon died in nine 22,
the structure that had been erected by
David and Solomon fell into these two
rival states, and neither of them, of
course, it's going to be very strong.
You have the northern Kingdom of Israel
and the southern kingdom referred to as
Judah, each with its own king,
right? Jeroboam in the north,
Rehoboam in the south. Sometimes they're
going to be at war with one another,
sometimes they're going to work
in alliance with one another. Um,
but 200 years later, right from nine 22
down to seven, 20 to 200 years later,
the northern kingdom of Israel
will fall to the Assyrian Empire.
The Assyrians come down to the border of
the southern kingdom to Judah and Judah
remains viable,
but it is reduced to a vassal status.
It is tributary to this new world power.
Finally,
Judah will be destroyed about 150 years
later. Okay, about five [inaudible] seven,
five 86 the Babylonians, right?
The Neo Babylonian Empire,
they have conquered the Assyrians and
they assume control over the ancient near
east and take the southern kingdom.
Now, the story of the northern kingdom,
Israel that's presented in kings is
colored by a Judy and perspective,
and it is highly negative
and highly polemical.
So Solomon was succeeded
by his son Rehoboam,
but the 10 tribes of
the north, um, revolted.
When he refused to
relieve their tax burden,
they came to him and asked if they could
have some relief and he answered them
very harshly.
So they revolted.
And a separate kingdom was set up under
the rule of the Israelite Jeroboam
towards it just till the
end of the 10th century.
So divided now into these two kingdoms,
they began to lose power,
probably losing any control they may
have had over outlying territories.
So let's focus first on the
northern kingdom of Israel.
The area was more divided by tribal
rivalries and religious traditions.
Then Judah,
you have 10 tribes in that region.
Gera bomb didn't seem to be able
to establish a very stable rule.
First Kings 12 tells us of Jeroboam
effort to break the connection with the
traditional religious center
of Jerusalem in the south.
He establishes his own
government at chef come.
And that was a place that was
already revered in Hebrew tradition.
This is where we have the Covenant
Renewal Ceremony by Joshua.
So it's already a somewhat sacred site.
So he establishes his
capital and check them.
And then he establishes Royal Shrines,
one in the southern part of,
of Israel and one in the northern part
of Israel, right on each of the borders,
north and south of the
kingdom in Dan and Bethel,
Bethel on the south and Dan and the north,
a golden calf is placed in each
shrine according to the text.
And this is viewed by the Deuteronomistic
historian as a terrible sin. Indeed,
the story is written in a manner that
deliberately echoes the story of the
golden calf that was made
by Aaron and Exodus 32.
There are linguistic echoes, um, uh,
that make it very clear that we
are supposed to view this as a sin,
as great as the sin of Aaron.
It may well be that if
Jeroboam did in fact do this,
that he was a good ya'll list and was
just trying to establish alternate
sanctuaries for Galloway Way,
um, that would rival Jerusalem's.
But the Deuteronomistic historian
wants to see this, um, in as,
as another instance of,
of idolatry and therefore deliberately
echoes the primordial cultic sin of the
golden calves when talking
about Jarrow bombs activity.
It brands his cultic center
as illegitimate idolatry.
Jeroboam is represented by the biblical
writer as having made unacceptable
concessions to Canaanite
practices of worship.
And so he is criticized for
this despite his best efforts,
his kingship is a fairly
unstable and in fact,
in the 200 year history of the kingdom,
the northern Kingdom of Israel,
we will have seven different
dynasties occupying the throne.
There was great miss material,
prosperity in the northern kingdom. Um,
I've just picked out a
few kings to highlight.
So these are not to be understood
to be necessarily in order.
I've just picked out a few highlights,
but I'm,
the rule of armory was a time of some
much material prosperity and his son Ahab
Ahab was sort of the first
part of the ninth century.
Amari is an interesting person because
he's the first king from either kingdom
to be mentioned in sources
outside the Bible. We have, um,
a large stone referred to as the
Moabite stone and this stone,
which boasts of a military defeat,
um, there's the boast that, um,
uh,
Omri of Israel was defeated.
Omri bought and fortified Samarria as
the capital of the northern Kingdom of
Israel.
And archeology does reveal that this
was in fact quite a magnificent city at
this time. But again, the Deuteronomistic
editors are going to judge him as evil.
He's disobeyed God.
His son Ahab also comes in for bad press.
Ahab is also mentioned outside the Bible.
We have an inscription of an
Assyrian king who describes, um,
a coalition of Israelites and Aramaeans
who fought against the Assyrians.
And Ahab is mentioned in that inscription.
Omri and Ahab were clearly very
powerful and influential and the region,
they're even mentioned outside the Bible.
Ahab and his Phoenician wife Jezza
bell seem to have established a very
extravagant court life in the
capital of area. And for this,
they're also going to be condemned
by the Deuteronomistic editors.
Jessebelle what's Phoenician?
And when Jezza bail tried to establish
the worship of her Phoenecian Baal as the
official cult of Israel and
she built a temple to buy.
I'll in some area the prophets,
Elijah and Elisha preach a kind
of holy war against the monarchy.
And we're going to come back to these
very zealous Yahweh only profits of the
north. When we talk about
prophecy next time, um,
it had been Jessebelle meet a very tragic
end and there will be a military coup,
military coup led by an army
general Jay who in about eight 42.
These are all kind of
approximate year as you know,
that you'll different books we'll give
them, they'll defer by five years,
one way or the other.
But it's our best effort at reconstructing
things based on some of these outside
extra biblical references that give us
a firm date and then we can kind of work
around those.
So the army general Jay,
who in about eight 42 led a military coup.
He was anointed king
by the Prophet Elijah,
and he had a very bloody
revenge on decibel decibel.
And the priests of Baal were
all slaughtered. The text says,
as was as well as every
worshiper of bowel in some area,
they were all slaughtered
by the eighth century.
You have the newest Syrian
empire on the rise. And in seven,
22 of the Assyrian King Sargon reduced
Israel to the status of a province.
And we have an inscription by Sargon that
confirms the Biblical report that this
defeat. And in this
inscription, Sargon says,
I besieged and conquered Sumeria led
away as booty 27,290 inhabitance of it.
The town I rebuilt better than it was
before and settled there in people from
countries which I myself had conquered.
So population trends transplanting,
I placed an officer of mine, has
governor over them and imposed upon them.
Tribute as is customary
for a Syrian citizens.
So there's a basic agreement between
this and the biblical account. Uh,
many of the governing class,
the wealthy merchants,
many tens of thousands in all were carried
off to northern Mesopotamia and they
were lost to history.
These are the 10 lost tribes of Israel.
There would have remained behind
some Hebrew farmers and shepherds.
They would have continued their old ways,
but as was consistent with their policy,
the in Syria,
the Assyrians imported new peoples to
repopulate this area and to break up any
local resistance to their rule.
Um,
and this would then become
the province of Symeria.
And this ethnically mixed group would
practice a form of Israelite religion,
but the Deuteronomistic editor
does not view it as legitimate.
And ultimately these Samaritans were
going to be despised by the Jews of the
southern kingdom,
the Jews of Judah.
They were seen as foreign
corruptors of the faith.
They were always ready to assist
Judah's enemies against Judah.
So they felt very little kinship.
And,
and very often the Samaritans would
join against those attacking Judah.
So there was tremendous rivalry between
the Jews of Judah and, um, the Samaritans,
hence the New Testament story. Makes
Sense, right? This is a hated person.
This good Samaritan.
So if we turn our attention now
to the southern Kingdom of Judah,
Judah comprised the two was comprised
of the two remaining tribes of Judah and
Benjamin. And it enjoyed internal
stability. For the most part,
it remained loyal to the house
of David ruling in Jerusalem.
Shortly after Israel fail fell
and seven 22 to the Assyrians,
the Judah Heights, who's king at
that time was king, has a Kia, right?
So the king king has a Kia,
had to agree to terms with a Syria.
They became sort of subject allies or,
or vassals of Assyria.
But Hezekiah began to
prepare for rebellion,
began to make alliances with neighbors.
And this prompted the Assyrians to
march in and lay siege to Jerusalem.
This would have happened about 701.
And this siege is described
in a Syrian sources.
So we have independent, um, uh,
records of this from a Syrian sources.
We read there as to Hezekiah,
the Jew of you,
of you who'd write the Jew.
He did not submit to my yoke.
I laid siege to 46 of his strong
cities, walled forts, et cetera.
I drove out 200,150 people himself.
I made prisoner in Jerusalem, his
royal residence, like a bird in a cage,
but eventually these Syrians
actually withdrew the siege.
Judah was able to withstand the
siege to preserve their own kingship.
The Assyrian Empire is going to fall in
six 12 this is the fall of Nineveh you
may have heard of at some point, and
they will fall to the rising Babylonians,
the neo Babylonian Empire.
It's the neo Babylonian Empire that will
succeed in felling Judah under new book
had Red Sir of Babylon in five 87 or
five 86 the walls of Jerusalem are
dismantled.
Many members of the governing classes,
wealthier classes are going to be
carried off into exile in Babylonia,
and that the Hebrews didn't fade into
oblivion after the loss of political
independence and their geographical
base is due in large part to the
interpretation of events provided
by the Deuteronomistic school.
So we need to talk a little bit about
that ideology and why it had historical
effect that it had.
As I mentioned before,
Deuteronomy isn't just the capstone of
the pentose doot Pentatonix narrative.
It's also the first part of
a longer literary history.
Martin note was a German scholar
who first argued for this,
argued that the composition and
authorship of Deuteronomy has great,
um, has more in common with what follows
in some sense then what precedes it.
Uh, and he argued that we should
understand this to be a unit,
the product of a particular school.
Um,
since this Deuteronomistic
school is looking back at
the history of Israel up to
and including the defeat and exile of
the Israelites and five 87 or five 86,
the final form of the work
of the Deuteronomistic
school, the final form must,
must be posting silly post five
86. Um, but there are of course,
various layers within that larger work
that we can't really date with precision.
I just want to say something about the
scholarly methodology that led to the
conclusion that there is such a
thing as the Deuteronomistic school.
And that method is redaction criticism.
And we've already discussed the goals
and the methods of other types of
criticism,
source criticism or historical criticism.
We've talked a little bit about form
criticism and tradition criticism,
but redaction criticism grew out of a
kind of weariness with some of these other
forms of biblical criticism.
And they're constant fragmentation of
the biblical text into older sources or
into older genres or into
older units of tradition.
In order to map out a history
of Israelite religion.
And these other methods seem to pay
very little attention to the text in its
final form and the process by which
the texts reached its final form.
So redaction criticism rejects the
idea that the person or the persons who
compiled the texts from earlier sources,
um,
did a somewhat mechanical scissors and
paste job didn't really think too much
about the effect. Um, they were
creating by putting things together,
redaction criticism assumes
and focuses on identifying, um,
the purpose and the plan behind the
final form of the assembled sources.
They want to uncover.
It's a method that wants to uncover the
intention of the person or the persons
who produced the biblical texts in
roughly the shape that we have at and what
was intended by they're producing
it in the shape that we have.
So redaction criticism
proceeds along these lines.
And this is how at first developed
first you can usually identify linking
passages.
That is to say passages that kind of join
narrative to narrative or unit to unit
in an attempt to make the text read more
smoothly or just to ease the transition
from one source to another.
And these linking passages are assigned
to our for redactor, right? Um,
also assigned to our are any interpretive
passages that means passages that
stand back to comment on the text
or interpret the text in Sunway.
Any place where the narrator
turns to direct the,
to directly address the audience.
So for example,
when you have a burst in which the
narrator turns and says that was when the
Canaanites were still in the land,
that would seem to be from the hand of
a redactor putting the sources together.
When you have an ed illogical comment
that is to say a comment of the type that,
and that is why the Israelites do such
and such a ritual observance to this day,
right?
That also seems to be written from the
perspective of a compiler of sources.
Someone who's putting the text together.
There are also some passages that indicate
or justify or otherwise comment on
what's about to occur or passages that
summarize and offer an interpretation or
justification of what has just happened.
We'll see that in second kings 17.
We also saw that in the book of judges,
we had this perspective summary
saying this is what's going to happen.
There's going to be sin. They're going
to cry out. There'll be, you know,
God will raise up someone,
they'll deliver them and then they're
going to fall back into sin again.
So these are comments that are um,
looking forward to tell us
what it is we're about to read.
And if you join all of all such passages
together and assign them to are,
you very often find that there are
tremendous stylistic similarities in these
passages.
They use the same rhetoric over and over
again or you'll see the same point of
view.
Um,
and it's very often a point of view
that isn't in the source materials that
they're,
that they're linking together.
And this is how one arrives
at some understanding of
the role of the redactor in
the final production of the text,
how the redactor has framed
our understanding of the
source materials that he
has gathered and the Deuteronomistic
historian who's responsible for the
reduction of Deuteronomy,
Joshua judges.
And so first and second Samuel First
and second kings provides not just a
history in the sense of
documenting events as they occur,
as if there's ever documentation
without interpretation,
but provides a strong interpretation
of history, of philosophy,
of history is trying to ascertain
the meaning of events, the largest,
the larger purpose and design something
we've called a historiography.
And we find the Deuteronomistic
interpretation of Israel's history in the
preface to the book of Deuteronomy.
We find it in editorial comments that
are sort of peppered throughout Joshua
through kings.
And we especially find it in the summary
of the entire unit that is contained in
second kings 17 before
we read that passage,
we need to think about what it was that
prompted the deuteronomist to adopt a
particular interpretation of
Israel's historical record.
The Deuteronomistic historian was
attempting to respond to the first major
historical challenge to confront the
Israelite people and the Hebrew religion.
And that was the complete
collapse of the Israelite nation,
the destruction of God's sanctuary and
the defeat and exile of the people of the
Lord and God in history.
The calamitous events of seven 22 but
especially five 87 raised a critical
theological dilemma.
God had promised the Patriarchs and
their descendants that they would live in
his land. He had promised that the
house of David would stand forever,
but here at the monarchy had collapsed.
The people were defeated
and they were in exile.
So the challenge presented by this
twist of history was really twofold.
Is God the God of history? Is he
omnipotent? Is He capable of all?
Can he in fact impose an effect his will?
And if so, then what about his covenant?
With the Patriarchs and his covenant with
David. Had He facelessly abandoned it.
Well,
that was unthinkable then.
If he hadn't facelessly abandoned his
covenant with his people and with David,
he must not be the god of history,
the universal Lord of all.
He wasn't able to save his people.
Neither of these ideas was acceptable
to the Deuteronomistic school.
It was a fundamental tenant of Israelite
monotheism that God is at once the god
of history,
capable of all whose will is absolute,
whose promises are true,
and at the same time a god of faithfulness
who does not abandon his people.
He is both good and powerful.
So how could the disasters of seven
22 and five 86 be reconciled with the
conviction that God controlled history
and that he had an Eternal Covenant with
the Patriarchs and with David?
The histories,
the history ossify of the Deuteronomistic
school is the response of one segment
of the Israelite community.
We'll see another response
when we turn to the profits.
But the basic idea of the Deuteronomistic
school is that God's unconditional and
eternal covenants with the Patriarchs
and with David do not preclude the
possibility of punishment or
chastisement for sin as specified in the
conditional mosaic covenant.
So you see how both ideas are going
to be important to hold and dialectic
tension,
both theologies,
the Covenant Theology as well as
the patriarchal and royal theology.
So this is because although God is
omnipotent, humans do have free will,
they can corrupt the divine plan.
So in the Deuteronomistic history,
the leaders of Israel are depicted as
having the choice of accepting God's way
or rejecting it.
God tries to help them.
He's constantly sending them profits who
yell at the kings and tell them what it
is God wants of them, but they continue
to make the wrong choice. They sin.
And ultimately that brings about fall
first of Israel and then of Judah.
And it's the idolatrous sins of the kings
that does it with the deposition and
the execution of the last
Davidic King Zedekiah,
the Deuteronomistic school reinterpreted
the Davidic Covenant in conditional
terms on the model of the Sinai Covenant,
the Mosaic Covenant according to
which God's favor toward the king,
depends on the king's loyalty to God.
And in this way,
the fall of the house of David could
be seen as justifiable punishment for
disobedient kings and rulers like
Monash Shay. We'll come back to him.
Remember the Davidic covenant that Nathan,
uh, proclaimed in second Samuel seven,
explicitly said that God would
punish and chastises anointed.
That's what it means to be a son,
to receive correction, discipline,
and punishment. I have to finish
this, these thoughts on, um,
on Monday and see if specifically how
they interpret it and understand the
history of what happened in a way
that enabled certain segments of the
population to see this as in fact,
proof of God's strength
and faith faithfulness. Um,
and then we'll turn to prophesy on Monday.